so you're saying that there is a gap
between the computer or the the
the machine that performs computation
and
this machine
that appears to have consciousness and
intelligence yeah can we um that piece
of meat in your head piece of meat and
maybe it's not just
the meat in your head it's the rest of
you too i mean you have you have you
actually have a neural system in your
gut um i i tend to also believe
not believe but
we're now dancing around things we don't
know but
i tend to believe other humans are
important
like so we're almost like
i i just don't think we would ever have
achieved the level of intelligence we
have with other humans
i'm not saying so confidently but i have
an intuition that some of the
intelligence is in the interaction yeah
and and i think
you know i think it it seems to be very
likely again we you know this is
speculation but
we our species and probably um
probably in the antithos to some extent
because you can find uh old bones where
they seem to be counting on them by
putting notches
um that when the in the neanderthals had
done we are able to put um
some of our stuff outside our body into
the world and then other people can
share it
and then we get these tools that become
shared tools and so there's a whole
coupling that
would not occur in you know
the single
deep learning network which was fed you
know all of literature or something
yeah the the the neural network can't um
step outside of itself but is there
is there some um
can we explore this dark room
uh a little bit and try to get at
something
what is the magic where does the magic
come from in the human brain that
creates the mind
what's your sense
as scientists
that try to understand it and try to
build it what are the directions
if followed might be productive is it
creative interactive robots
is it creating large deep neural
networks that uh do like self-supervised
learning and just like wolf well
we'll discover that when you make
something large enough some interesting
things will emerge is it through physics
and chemistry biology like artificial
life angle like we'll sneak up in this
four quadrant
matrix that you mentioned is there
anything
your most if you have to bet all your
money
financially i wouldn't
okay so
every intelligence we know and includes
you know animal intelligence dog
intelligence you know uh
octopus intelligence which is very
different sort of architecture from from
us
all the intelligences we know
perceive the world
in some way
and then have action
in the world
but they're able to um
perceive objects in a way which is
actually pretty damn
for not phenomenal
and surprising
you know we tend to think you know that
um
that that uh
the box over here between us which is a
sound box i think is a blue box but
blueness um is something that we
construct with with um
color constancy it's not it's not a it's
not the blueness is not a direct
function of the
photons we're receiving it's actually
context you know which is why
you can turn uh you know you you've
maybe seen the examples where
um
someone turns a stop sign into a
um some other sort of sign by just
putting a couple of marks on them and
the deep learning system gets it wrong
everyone says but the stop sign's red
you know why is it why is it think it's
the other sort of sign because redness
is not intrinsic in just the photons
it's actually a construction of an
understanding of the whole world and the
relationship between objects to get
color constancy um but our tendency in
order that we get an archive paper
really quickly is you just show a lot of
data and give the labels and hope it
figures it out but it's not figuring it
out in the same way we do we have a very
complex perceptual understanding of the
world dogs have a very different
perceptual understanding based on smell
they go smell smell a post they can tell
um
how many
you know different dogs have visited it
in the last 10 hours and how long ago
there's all sorts of stuff that we just
don't perceive about the world and just
taking a single snapshot is not
perceiving about the world it's not
seeing the the registration between us
and the object and registration is a
philosophical concept brian cantwell
smith talks about a lot very difficult
squirmy thing to understand
but i think none of our systems do that
we've always talked about the symbol
grounding problem how symbols that we
talk about are grounded in the world
and when deep learning came along and
started labeling images people said ah
the grounding problem has been solved no
the labeling problem was solved with
some percentage accuracy which is
different from the grounding problem
so you uh
there's uh you agree with hans marvik
and
what's called the marvex paradox
that highlights this counterintuitive
notion that
reasoning
is easy
but perception
and mobility are hard
yeah we shared an office when um
when i was working on computer vision
and he was working on his first mobile
robot what were those conversations like
they were great
so do you still kind of maybe you can
elaborate and do you still believe this
kind of notion that
perception is really
uh hard and like can you make sense of
why we humans have this poor intuition
about what's hard and not well well let
me let me give a sort of
an another another story sure
if you go back to you know the original
um you know teams working on ai um
from the late 50s into the 60s you know
and you go to the ai lab at mit um
who was it that was doing that was a
bunch of really smart kids who got into
mit
and they were intelligent
so what's intelligence about well the
stuff they were good at playing chess
doing integrals
that was that was hard stuff
but you know a baby could see stuff that
wasn't that wasn't intelligent
anyone could do that that's not
intelligence
and so it you know this there was this
intuition that the hard stuff is the
things they were good at
and the easy stuff was the stuff that
everyone could do yeah and maybe i'm
overplaying it a little bit but i think
there's an element of that yeah i mean
there
i don't know how much truth there is to
uh like chess for example
has was for the longest time seen as the
highest
level of intellect
right
until we got computers so we're better
at it than people and then
we realized you know if you go back to
the 90s you'll see you know the stories
in the press around when when
kasparov was beaten by the blue oh this
is the end of all sorts of things
computers are going to be able to do
anything from now on and we saw exactly
the same stories with alpha zero the
go playing program
yeah
but still to me reasoning is a special
thing and perhaps no way we actually we
we're really bad at reasoning we just
use these analogies based on our
hunter-gatherer intuitions but why is
that not don't you think the ability to
construct metaphor
is a really powerful thing oh yeah this
is stories it is that's it's the
constructing the metaphor and
registering that yeah something close
like isn't that what we're doing with
with vision too and we're telling our
stories we're constructing good models
of the world
yeah yeah but but um
i think we we jumped between what we're
capable of and how we're doing it right
there it was a little confusion that
went on um
as we were telling each other stories
yes exactly
trying to dilute each other no i just
think uh i'm not exactly so i'm trying
to pull apart this marvex paradox
i don't view it as a paradox
what did evolution what did evolution
spend its time on yes it spent its time
on getting us to perceive and move in
the world that was you know 600 million
years as multi-cell creatures doing that
and then it was you know relatively
recent that we that we you know were
able to
um hunt or or gather or you know even
even animals hunting that's much more
recent and then and then anything that
we you know
speech uh language those things are you
know a couple of hundred thousand years
probably if if it's that long and then
agriculture 10 000 years you know
all that stuff was built on top of those
earlier things which took a long time to
develop
so if you then look at the engineering
of these things so building it into
robots
what's the hardest part of robotics do
you think
as uh through the decades that you
worked on robots
in the context of what we're talking
about vision you know perception
the actual sort of the
the biomechanics of movement
i'm kind of drawing parallels here
between humans and machines always like
uh what do you think is the hardest part
of robotics
i sort of think all of them
there are no easy parts to do well
um
we we sort of go reductionist and we
reduce it if only we had all the
location of all the points in 3d yeah
things would be great
you know if only we had labels on the on
the images you know
things would be great but you know as as
we see that's not good enough some
deeper
understanding but if you if i came to
you
and i could solve
one category of problems in robotics
uh instantly
what would give you uh the greatest
pleasure
i mean is it uh
you know you you look at robots that
manipulate objects
uh
what's hard about that you know is it uh
the perception
is it the uh the reasoning about the
world like common sense reasoning
is it the actual
building a robot that's able to interact
with the world
is it like human aspects of a robot
that's interacting with humans and that
that game theory of how they work well
together well let's talk about
manipulation for a second because i had
this really blinding
moment
uh
you know i'm a grandfather so
grandfather's had blinding moments yes
just
three or four miles from here
last year my
16 month old grandson was in his new
house
first time
right
first time in this house
and he'd never
been able to get to a window before but
this had some low windows
and he goes up to this window with a
handle on it that he's never seen before
and he's got one hand pushing the window
and the other hand turning the handle to
open the window
he he knew he two different hands
two different things he knew how to how
to put together yeah
and he's 16 months old and there you are
watching in awe
yeah
in an environment environment he'd never
seen before mechanism how did he do that
yes that's a good question how do we do
that that's why
it's like okay like you could see the
the leap of genius from using one hand
to perform a task to combining
doing i mean first of all in
manipulation that's really difficult
it's like two hands
both necessary to complete the action
and completely different and he'd never
seen a window open before
but in third somehow handle open
something yeah there may have been a lot
of um
slightly different failure cases that
you didn't see
yeah not with a window but with other
objects of turning and twisting in
handles
you know there's a there's a great
counter to
um you know
reinforce reinforcement learning will
just give you know the robot um
or you give the robot plenty of time to
try everything yes actually
can i tell a little side story here
so i'm in um
deep mind in london um this is
three four years ago where um you know
there's a big google building and then
you go inside and they go through this
more security and then you get to deep
mind where the other google employees
can't go yeah and i'm in a
i'm in a conference room bare conference
room with some of the people
and
they tell me about their reinforcement
learning experiment with uh robots um
um which um
are just trying stuff out and they're my
robots they're they're sawyers that we
sold them
um
and they really like him because sawyers
are compliant and can sense forces so
they don't break when it's bashing into
walls they they stop and they do stuff
and you know so you just let the robot
do stuff and eventually it figures stuff
out by the way
we're talking about robot manipulation
so robot arms and so on yeah so so he's
a robot yeah um just you know what's
sawyer so here's a robot arm that my
company rethink robotics yeah built
thank you for the contest sorry okay
cool so we're indeed mine
and the you know it's in the next room
these robots are just bashing around to
try and use reinforcement learning to
learn how to act and can i go see them
oh no they're secret
they're all my robots they're a secret
that's hilarious okay anyway the point
is you know this idea that you just let
uh reinforcement learning figure
everything out is so counted at how a
kid does stuff
so
again story about my grandson i gave him
this this uh
box that had lots of different lock
mechanisms
he didn't random you know and he was 18
months old he didn't randomly try to
touch every surface or push everything
he found he could see what where the
mechanism was and he started exploring
the mechanism for each of these
different lock mechanisms
and there was reinforcement no doubt of
some sort going on there
but he applied a pre-filter which cut
down the search space dramatically i
i wonder to what level we're able to
introspect what's going on because
what's also possible is you have
something like reinforcement learning
going on in the mind in the space of
imagination so like you have a good
model of the world you're predicting and
you may be running those tens of
thousands of like
loops but you're like as a human you're
just looking at yourself trying to tell
a story of what happened and it might
seem simple but maybe there's a lot of
computation going on whatever it is but
there's also a mechanism that's being
built up it's not just
random search
that mechanism prunes it
dramatically yeah that that pruning
uh that pruning stuff but it doesn't
it's possible that that's
so you don't think that's akin to a
neural network inside a reinforcement
learning algorithm
is it possible
it's
yeah and until it's possible i uh but
but i you know
um
i i
i'll be
incredibly surprised if that happens
i'll also be incredibly surprised that
you know after all the decades that i've
been doing this where every every few
years someone thinks now we've got it
now we've got it
you know
four or five years ago i was saying i
don't think we've got it yet and
everyone was saying no you don't
understand how powerful ai is i had
people tell me you don't understand how
powerful it is
um i you know i i
i sort of had a uh
a track record of what the world had
done to think well this is no different
from before
or we have bigger computers we had
bigger computers in the 90s and we could
do more stuff
but okay so let me let me push back
because i i'm i'm generally sort of
optimistic and tried to find the beauty
in things
um i think there's a lot of uh
surprising and beautiful things that
neural networks this new generation of
deep learning revolution has revealed to
me it has continually been very
surprising the kind of things it's able
to do now generalizing that over saying
like this we've solved intelligence
that's another
uh big leap but is there something
surprising and beautiful to you about
neural networks that where actually you
set back and said i i did not expect
this
oh i think i think their performance
their performance on imagenet was
shocking the computer vision those early
days was just very like wow okay that
doesn't mean that they're solving
everything in computer vision
we need to solve or in
vision for robots what about alpha zero
and self-play mechanisms and
reinforcement learning isn't that yeah
that was all in donald mickey's 1961
paper um
everything that was there which
introduced reinforcement learning um no
but come on so no you're talking about
the actual techniques but isn't it
surprising to you the level it's able to
achieve with no human supervision
of chess play like
to me there's a big big difference maybe
blue and maybe what that's saying
is how overblown our view of ourselves
is
you know we that chest is easy
yeah i mean i i i
came across this
report
that um and i'd seen this as a kid in
one of those books that my mother had
given me actually
um 1946 report which pitted
someone with an abacus against an
electronic calculator
and he beat the electronic calculator
you know so there at that point was well
humans are still better than
machines are calculating are you
surprised today that a machine can you
know do a billion floating point
operations a second and you know you're
you're puzzling for for minutes through
one
so you know
i i am i mean i don't know but i am
certainly surprised
there's something
uh to me different about learning
so system that's able to learn learning
now see now you get into one of the
deadly sins
because
of using terms overly broadly yeah i
mean there's so many different forms of
learning yeah and so many different
forms you know i learned my way around
the city i learned to play chess i
learnt latin
i learned to ride a bicycle all of those
are
you know a very different capabilities
yeah and
if someone
you know has a
in you know in the old days people would
write a paper about learning something
now the corporate uh press office puts
out a press release about how
company x has
has
is leading the world because they have a
system that can
yeah but here's the thing okay so what
is learning
what i refer to learning there's many
things but
a suitcase would it's a suitcase word
but
loosely
there's a dumb system
and over time
it becomes smart
well it becomes less dumb at the thing
that it's doing yeah smart is a
mass is a loaded word yes less less
dominant the thing is it gets better
performance under some measure yeah and
some set of conditions
at that thing and and most of these
learning algorithms um
learning systems
fail when you change the conditions just
a little bit in a way that humans don't
so right i was that deep mind
the alphago had just come out and i said
what would have happened if you'd given
a 21 by 21 board instead of a 19 by 19
board they said fail totally but a human
player would actually you know well
would actually be out of play and
actually funny enough if you look at
deepmind's work uh since then
uh they are pers
uh
they're presenting a lot of algorithms
that would do uh
the that would do well at the at the
bigger board so they're slowly expanding
this generalization i mean to me there's
a core element there i think it is very
surprising to me that even in a
constrained game of chess or go
that through self-play by a system
playing itself
that can it can
achieve super human level performance
through learning alone so like okay so
so you know you you didn't don't find
them as you did in search of that you
didn't you didn't like it when i
referred to
donald mickey's 1961 paper there in the
second
part of it it came a year later they had
self-play on an electronic computer at
tic-tac-toe okay
but it learnt to play tic-tac-toe
through self-play that's not and i've
learned to play optimally what i'm
saying is
uh i
okay i have a little bit of a bias but
i i find ideas beautiful but only when
they actually
realize the promise that's another level
of beauty like for example
uh what the
bezos and elon musk are doing with
rockets we had rockets for a long time
but doing reusable cheap rockets it's
very impressive in the same way
i okay yeah i would have not predicted
first of all when i was uh
started and fell in love with ai the
game of go was seen to be impossible to
solve
okay so i thought
maybe you know i
maybe it'd be possible to maybe have big
leaps in a moore's law style of way in
computation i'll be able to solve it but
i would never have guessed that you
could learn your way
however
i mean
in the narrow sense of learning learn
your way to
to to beat the best people in the world
at the game of go without human
supervision not studying the game of
experts
but okay so so
using a different learning technique yes
arthur samuel
in the early 60s and he was the first
person to use machine learning got had a
program that could beat the world
champion at checkers
now yes so and that at the time was
considered amazing by the way arthur
samuel had some fantastic advantages
yeah do you want to hear although
two things one he was at the 1956 um ai
conference a new arthur later in life he
was at stanford when i was scratching
there he wore a tie and a jacket every
day the rest of us didn't
um he's a
delightful man delightful man um
uh
it turns out claude shannon in a 1950
scientific american article
uh outlined
on chess playing outline the learning
mechanism that arthur samuel used um and
they had met in 1956 i assume there was
some communication but i don't know that
for sure but arthur samuel
had been a vacuum tube engineer on
getting reliability of vacuum tubes and
then had overseen
um the first transistorized computers at
ibm
and in those days
before you shipped a computer you ran it
for a week to see to get early failures
so he had this whole farm of computers
running random code
for hours and hours
a week for each computer we had a whole
bunch of them so he ran his chest
learning program uh with self-play
on on ibm's production line he had more
computation available to him than anyone
else in the world and then he was able
to produce a chess playing program i
mean a checkers playing program that
could beat the world champion
so that's amazing the question is
what i mean surprised i don't just mean
it's nice to have that accomplishment
is there is
a stepping towards something that feels
uh
more intelligent
than before the question is that's in
your view of the world okay well let me
then it doesn't mean i'm wrong
no no
so the question is if we keep taking
steps like that how far that takes us
are we going to build the better
recommender systems are we going to
build better robots okay or will we
solve intelligence so
you know i'm putting my bet on
um
but still missing a whole lot a lot um
and and why would i say that well in
these games they're all you know 100
information games
but again but each of these systems is a
very uh short description of the current
state
um
which is different from registering and
perception in the world okay which gets
back to maura vx paradox i'm definitely
not saying that uh
uh
chess is somehow harder than uh
perception
or uh any kind of even any kind of
robotics in the physical world i i
definitely think is is way harder than
the game of chess so i'm i was always
much more impressed by like the workings
of the human mind that's incredible the
human mind is incredible i've i believe
that from the very beginning to be a
psychiatrist for the longest time i
always thought that's way more
incredible in the game of chess i think
the game of chess is uh
i love the olympics it's just another
example of us humans picking a task and
then agreeing that a million humans will
dedicate their whole life to that task
and that's the cool thing that the human
mind is able to focus on one task and
then compete against each other and
achieve like weirdly incredible levels
of performance that's the aspect of
chess that's super cool not that chest
in itself uh is really difficult it's
it's it's like the fermat's last theorem
is not in itself to me that interesting
the fact that uh thousands of people
have been struggling to solve that
particular problem is fascinating so can
i tell you my disease in this way sure
which actually is closer to what you're
saying so as a child you know i was
building various i called them computers
they weren't
general purpose computers ice cube tray
the ice cube tray was one but i built
other machines and what i like to build
was machines that could beat adults at a
game and they couldn't they adults
couldn't beat my machine yeah so you
were like uh that's powerful like that's
uh that's a way to rebel
yeah i i by the way um
did you
when was the first time you built
something that outperformed you do you
remember like
well i knew how it worked i was probably
nine years old and i built a thing that
it was a game where you you take turns
and taking
matches from a pile and the either the
one who takes the last one or the one
who doesn't take the last one wins i
forget and so it was pretty easy to
build that out of wires and nails and
little coils that were like plugging in
the number and a few light bulbs
um the one the one i was proud of i was
12 when i i built a
uh a thing out of old
telephone switchboard switches that
could uh always uh win at tic-tac-toe
and that was a much harder circuit
to design but again it was just
it was no active components it was just
three position switches empty x
zero
and um
and nine of them and and a light bulb
one which which move it wanted next and
then yeah the human would go and move
that see there's magic in that creation
yeah yeah i tend to uh i tend to see
magic in robots that
like i i also think that intelligence is
uh is a little bit overrated i think we
can have deep connections with robots
very soon
and well
we'll come back to connections robot
sure but but i do want to say i i don't
i i think people too many people make
the mistake of seeing that magic
and thinking well we'll just continue
you know but each each one of those is a
hard-fought battle for the next step the
next step yes i mean the open question
here is and this is why i'm playing
devil's advocate but i often do when i
read your blog post in my mind
because i have like this eternal
optimism is it's not clear to me
so i don't do what obviously the
journalists do or they give into the
hype but it's not obvious to me how many
steps away we are from
from a
truly
transformational
understanding of what it means um
to build intelligence systems like or
how to build intelligence systems
i'm also aware of the whole history of
artificial intelligence which is where
your deep grounding of this is
is there's been an optimism for decades
and that optimism just like reading old
optimism is absurd because people were
like
this is they were saying things are
trivial for decades since the 60s
they're saying everything is true
computer vision is trivial but
i think my mind is
working crisply enough to where i mean
we can dig into if if you want i'm
really surprised by
the things deepmind has done i don't
think they're so they're yet
close to solving intelligence but i'm
not sure it's not 10 to 10 years away
what i'm referring to it's interesting
to see when the engineering
it takes that idea to scale
you